an American journalist was imprisoned
and killed in a Ukrainian prison simply
for voicing his opinion that journalist
is Gonzalo lra I'm totally unfamiliar
with his work I've never watched a video
of his I I take it that he's popular on
YouTube and in some of the the
manosphere and the red pill circles bit
eccentric and he was over in Ukraine and
he was arrested for voicing his opinion
on that war and not sufficiently
supporting the zalinsky regime and so
they arrested him they imprisoned him
his health started to fail the
ukrainians didn't lift a finger it seems
to help him the US state department
didn't lift a finger it seems to help
him and then he died how are more people
not talking about this all we ever hear
about especially from the left-wing
press in America is how those
journalists they're the fourth estate
the Intrepid Defenders of democracy we
need to stop all those autocratic
regimes from silencing the Press killing
the press in this case oh unless it's
sininsky